wild swings roil the stock market as the
federal reserve plans a rate hike the
biden administration pulls its vax
mandate but proposes a new one and joe
biden warns that russia's ukraine
invasion could change the world i'm
bench bureau this is the bench bureau
show
this is the ben shapiro show and it is
sponsored by expressvpn thousands of my
listeners have already secured their
network data join them at
expressvpn.com we'll get all the news in
just one moment first you shouldn't be
spending as much as you are spending on
your cell phone bill you're just
spending way too much money i know
you've got att or verizon or t-mobile
because they have the great cell network
and all of that here's the thing you
could have that same cell network except
be paying half the price and you
wouldn't be giving your money to a
company that would then send that money
to joe biden nancy pelosi and chuck
schumer you should be using pure talk
pure talk as i've said uses the exact
same tower same 5g network as one of the
big companies but with the peace of mind
that you are supporting a veteran run
business a business whose employees are
right here in the united states so this
is one monthly bill you can be proud to
pay and by the way it will probably be
about half of what your current cell
phone bill is because the average family
saves over 800 dollars a year so that's
a great deal head on over to
peertalk.com find the plan that is right
for you find the phone that is right for
you or just bring your own then because
they love my listeners enter promo code
ben shapiro and you will say 50
off your very first month of coverage
that is puretalk.com
promo code ben shapiro go check them out
right now puretalk.com promo code ben
shapiro to get started say 50 off your
first month and hundreds of dollars down
the road at puretalk.com promo code ben
shapiro alrighty so the stock market is
just bouncing around like crazy as
everybody expects the federal reserve to
announce a rate hike any day now that
rate hike would probably take effect in
march according to the wall street
journal
u.s stock indices tumbled partly
recovered and then retreated again in a
second straight day of tumultuous
trading highlighting investor anxiety
over the likely path of federal reserve
interest rate increases ahead of the
central bank's regular meeting tuesday's
trading continues a topsy-turvy start to
2022 for stocks which has dragged the s
p 500 down 8.6 percent on track for the
worst month since march 2020. all three
major indices fell on tuesday though
they closed well off session lows the s
p 500 fell 1.2 percent the technology
heavy nasdaq fell 2.3 percent and the
blue chip
dow jones industrial average closed down
0.2
the moves followed another jarring
infrared reversal on monday the day
recovered from losses of more than a
thousand points for the first time in
history the nasdaq recorded its biggest
reversal since 2008 what this really
does betray is the simple fact that
nobody really knows whether we're about
to enter a recession or
whether this is all sort of transitory
based on joe biden's crappy policy the
hope is that when the federal reserve
hikes the interest rates there'll be a
temporary spike in unemployment and then
the economy will sort of even out
because we won't have the superheated
inflation we've seen under joe biden
also the hope is that because joe biden
really does not have control of congress
at this point that we have hidden end to
the artificial stimulus that has driven
exorbitant spending and massive bubbles
in literally every area of the economy
so investors who are smart are doing
what you usually do in buying the dip
and this is what i'm doing you know i
never give investment advice but here is
my investment advice buy the dip do not
start selling off all of your stocks if
you can afford to wait it out wait it
out my favorite stock market story is
the warren buffett story it may be
apocryphal i think it's not in which
warren buffett was asked in 2008 about
having lost a billion dollars over the
course of the stock market crash
and he said what are you talking about i
didn't lose any money they said well but
look at your stock portfolio what it's
worth he said i sell it right this is
the key if you don't actually realize
the losses the losses don't exist in the
same way if you don't realize the gains
the gains do not exist okay that said it
is joe biden's crappy policy that is
leading to all this uncertainty in the
markets
in fact the federal reserve is likely to
signal a march interest rate hike and
that policy tightening is coming
according to cnbc the federal reserve is
expected to signal at its meeting this
week it is ready to raise interest rates
as soon as march and that it will
consider other policy tightening
reversing the easy policies it put in
place to fight the pandemic the fed
begins its two-day meeting on tuesday on
wednesday afternoon the central bank is
expected to issue a new statement that
shows it is resolved to fight inflation
against the backdrop of a violent stock
market correction fed officials are
expected to say they are ready to push
up the fed funds rate from zero as soon
as march mark cubana the head of u.s
short rate strategy bank of america says
we don't expect them to sound dovish the
bond market seems to be reacting to the
drop in equities plus the geopolitical
tensions so maybe the fed sounds not as
hawkish as the otherwise would be but we
don't think the fed is going to come out
and tell the market it's wrong for
pricing in four rate hikes this year
four rate hikes would be a lot of rate
hikes this year this is because of
course of the superheated monetary
policy pursued not only during the biden
administration but in 2020 when the
federal government's preferred strategy
was to tell you to stay home and then
pour money into your pocket rather than
pursuing something that looked like a
reasonable strategy whereby we shielded
the vulnerable and told everybody else
to go back to work
according to cnbc the fed has found
itself in its first major battle with
inflation in decades after two years of
super easy policies implemented to
counter the economic and financial
impact of the pandemic the consumer
price index in december rose 7 which was
the highest in 40 years since
1982 the stock market sell-off has
actually made the fed's job more
difficult because with the stock market
dipping into correction territory and
the pandemic continuing and russia
threatening military action against
ukraine the fed is worried that if they
raise the rates at this point that the
economy is still grappling with
uncertainty
pal is supposed to brief the media today
the fed is releasing its announcement at
2 p.m on wednesday and again his tone is
expected to sound hawkish also the fed
has been discussing paying back their
nearly nine trillion dollar balance
sheet which more than doubled during the
pandemic at their december meeting
central bank officials discussed the
balance sheet some strategists expect
the wind down to begin in june or even
as early as may and remember what the
federal reserve tends to do is it buys
up all sorts of assets from the market
in order to inject money into the
economy the central bank's asset
purchase program scheduled 10 in march
has been the primary contributor to the
size of the balance sheet the fed has
been buying 120 billion dollars of
treasury and mortgage securities a month
but has been tapering back once it ends
the program then they have to figure out
exactly how they sell all of these
assets they currently own the fed
currently replaces securities that are
maturing with market purchases it could
change that operation and make other
moves like altering the duration of the
securities it holds trying to
put those assets back on the market and
suck some money out of the economy
apparently
this is having an impact on the market
obviously
barry knapp the head of research at
ironside's macroeconomics said the stock
market's decline was not a surprise the
11 drop in the s p 500 as of monday was
consistent with the average decline
after other fed tightening moves again
none of this had to be pursued in the
first place loose monetary policy was
at least largely the cause
of the 2008 crash it is now going to be
the cause of whatever comes next right
here
meanwhile the united states is
experiencing a significant problem with
computer chips so
the historian neil ferguson he has
suggested in the past that the future
wars will not be fought over resources
like oil or gas or coal the future wars
will be fought over microchips because
it is the supply of chips that is going
to determine the technological
development of the future right now the
united states is in a bad situation
because so many of the manufacturers of
this sort of hardware
are not in the united states according
to the washington post manufacturers and
other buyers of computer chips had less
than five days supply of some chips on
hand late last year leaving them
vulnerable to any disruption in
deliveries according to the commerce
department the report highlighted the
severity of a global shortage that has
hobbled manufacturing and fueled
inflation for more than a year and that
defies easy solutions manufacturers
media and chip inventory levels have
plummeted from about 40 days supplies in
2019 to five days according to a survey
of 150 companies worldwide the commerce
department conducted in september the
commerce department concluded quote this
means a disruption overseas which might
shut down a semiconductor plant for two
to three weeks has the potential to
disable a manufacturing facility and
furlough workers in the united states if
that facility only has three to five
days of inventory
the lack of chip inventory leaves auto
manufacturers and other chip users with
no room for error and remember of course
that these chips are in everything
they're in your cell phone they're in
your computers they're in your cars
according to the commerce secretary gina
raimondo she says a coveted outbreak a
storm a natural disaster political
instability problems with equipment
really anything that disrupts a chip
making facility anywhere in the world we
will feel the ramifications here in the
united a coveted outbreak in malaysia
has the potential to shut down a
manufacturing facility here in america
that's why raimondo is urging lawmakers
to pass a proposal for 52 billion in
federal subsidies to incentivize
construction of chip factories
and this actually is is not the worst
idea in the world i mean the simple fact
is that for national security purposes
there are certain industries that the
united states needs to in-source rather
than outsource we saw this with regard
to medical equipment and ppe during the
pandemic this also obviously exists with
regard to chip production because if the
chips disappear off the world market and
the united states is left holding the
bag meanwhile all of the chip production
facilities are in china
and china is exerting for example
control over the shipping lanes with
regard to taiwan that's a disaster area
for the united states the senate did
pass the measure last year after months
of delay the house on tuesday introduced
its own version of the legislation which
matches the senate's 52 billion
appropriation in a statement speaker
pelosi says she aims to get the bill to
the president's desk as soon as possible
industry executives say federal funding
is likely to create more long-term
supply of ships but it's not going to
alleviate the short-term shortages
because chip factories take years to
build
survey respondents said these shortages
are not going to go away in the six
months in the next six months some
industry executives say they could last
into 2023.
the report found computer chips based on
older technology are in short supply
creating special problems for
manufacturers including automakers and
boosting production of that sort of chip
will be challenging because the profit
margins aren't nearly as high obviously
because these are older chips and they
are not driven toward the future
a lack of chips forced auto
manufacturers worldwide to idle
factories and slash output by as much as
7.7 million cars last year causing
shortages of new and used vehicles that
collapse in auto sales to consumers
because of the chip shortage shaved more
than two percentage points from us gdp
growth in the third quarter alone
okay the the united states has uh has
failed to insource some of this because
we're reliant on global supply chains
listen i'm a fan of global supply chains
it is what allows you to have a cheap
iphone however the fact is that when you
are relying on countries like china and
not countries like say malaysia or
indonesia or taiwan for your chips you
got a real problem and this is why
global politics matter when it comes to
foreign policy
it really matters who is in control of
the resources it really does matter how
these supply lanes are kept open it
really does matter whether the areas in
the world that are most responsible for
the mining of rare earth's minerals fall
into the hands of opponents of the
united states
and this is why the sort of isolationist
let's keep our hands off routine that
doesn't work particularly well when you
are talking about ensuring that the
united states remains a global
superpower
some lawmakers like bernie sanders voice
opposition to the subsidy saying the
semiconductor industry is highly
profitable and doesn't need federal aid
but that's really not the question
the point that raimondo is making and
she is correct is that the cost of
building ship factories is higher here
in the united states
so generally i'm not in favor of
subsidies the only reason that i'd be in
favor of a subsidy here is because it's
an actual national security issue
and the fact that all of this is
happening is a reflection of course a
bad policy from the top down you can't
blame joe biden for the shortage in chip
manufacturing here in the united states
right now except that he was vice
president under barack obama when we
really didn't do enough to increase our
chip production here in the united
states and in source a lot of the vital
manufacturing production that we need in
the united states i'm not a fan of
cracking down on free trade because we
have to subsidize american industry just
per se i am a fan of ensuring that
america's opponents don't have control
over vital choke points in the global
economy and also making sure that
america's opponents do not have control
of the things that we need in order to
ensure that our economy keeps running
but this is not a competent
administration and so i really don't
trust them to get us on track
unfortunately in just one second we'll
get to ron clayne who is now receiving
these sort of
the the sort of do smacking around that
he should be getting because the media
have to find somebody other than buying
to blame so ron clayne's head is now
going to be on the chopping block first
let's talk about timing the market so
we've been talking about here the
mortgage rates are likely to rise right
the fed is going to start tapering when
the fed starts tapering you can expect
those mortgage rates to rise so if you
want to sneak in under the wire with a
good mortgage refi now would be the time
the latest forecasts project a few
interest rate hikes this year the first
increase could come in the next month
that means now is the time to call
american financing take advantage of a
free no obligation mortgage review you
will learn about custom loan options
that can save you up to a thousand
dollars a month from lower rates to
shorter terms even debt consolidation
they can do it all and they never charge
upfront or hidden fees so why not see
what they can do for you if you like
what you hear you can pre-qualify for
free and possibly skip two mortgage
payments plus you may close in as fast
as 10 days just call 866 721 3300 that
is 866 721 3300 or visit
americanfinancing.net
nmls182 334 nmls consumeraccess.org go
check them out americanfinancing.net
give them a call 866 721 3300 that is
866 721 3300 or visit
americanfinancing.net because your rates
aren't going to get better and they
could get worse so now would be the time
to do it american americanfinancing.net
alrighty ron klain coming in for some do
fire thanks to the washington post they
have a piece titled ron clayne had the
perfect resume his first year showed the
limits of that experience they didn't
have the perfect resume actually just
turns out he's crappy at his job
according to the washington post as joe
biden closed in on the 2020 democratic
presidential nomination top advisors
approached him with a careful process
for choosing and vetting a potential
white house chief of staff biden cut
them short pointing to one man whose
experience in government outstripped
anyone else
i want ron
but throughout his first year on the job
ron clayne and his sterling credentials
have repeatedly bumped up against
unusual challenges of governing in
today's washington he drew the ire of
key democrats in congress antagonizing
both speaker nancy pelosi and senator
joe manchin on the single biggest
challenge facing the white house claim
at times irked the administration's top
official in charge of covered response
pushing jeff zions and his team to move
faster in ways they found
counterproductive
claim 60 is praised by many in the white
house and on capitol hill for his
responsiveness and organizational
abilities and most important is said by
close associates of president biden to
retain his confidence but even some
allies suggest that claine's approach is
not necessarily producing the desired
results senator richard blumenthal
democrat of connecticut says i think by
and large he's making the trains run on
time even though some of the box cars
may seem to be empty some of the time
this account of claims turbulent year is
based on interviews with more than 60
white house and administration officials
cabinet secretaries members of congress
and other claim associates many talked
on the record some spoke on condition of
anonymity because they didn't want to
offend anybody
white house aides have been highly
protective of claims image his team
arranged interviews for this article
with senior west wing officials whom
they rarely make available for articles
involving white house policy or
political strategy claim himself talked
with the washington post he said we're
going to try to find ways to do
congressional meetings earlier in the
day later in the day so maybe during the
day joe biden can go out be in public he
could even travel and just try to lessen
the extent to which it becomes the
central narrative about what he's doing
with his time
many allies and even some critics say
claim is the best choice for the job
they point to the white house success in
creating jobs and vaccinating millions
of americans among the strongest
criticisms of claim however come from
democrats who say that he has forged an
alliance with the parties left that has
undercut biden's effectiveness and hurt
his political image
the sore point was biden's decision in
late october not to press house
democrats to vote immediately for the
bipartisan infrastructure bill as pelosi
and her allies wanted liberal democrats
preferred to wait until they could
ensure that they could push build back
better biden's senior staff was united
behind his decision to hold off
according to a white house official
but many people were pissed off at
ronclain because of his frequent
conversations with congressional
progressive caucus chairwoman carmilla
drypal so in other words the infighting
has now begun inside the white house joe
biden has stood by claim even though
klein has shifted well to the left
apparently claine says he has no
timetable for staying in his position he
hinted that he could take only so much
he noted that the first chiefs of staff
were presidents bill clinton and barack
obama left before the two years were up
so claine is uh claiming that the clock
is ticking on him of course i do love
how the washington post describes claim
claim's resume is almost impossibly
glittering impossibly
he worked for biden on his first
presidential run in 1987. i'm not sure
why that's a credential biden had to
drop out after a plagiarism scandal he
graduated that year from harvard law
school where he graduated magna and was
an editor on the harvard law review he
then clerked for the supreme court he
served as associate counsel in the
clinton white house and was biden's
chief of staff when he was vice
president
clayne's office sits just down the hall
from biden's insides it's a large white
poster board sectioned off as a monthly
calendar plastered with sticky notes
which he said he uses during saturday
meetings to map out what the president
does
white house officials say clain
regularly pokes funded himself and his
twitter habit in meetings sometimes
expressing his opinion with the caveat
i'm just a middle-aged overweight white
guy they also regularly give him a hard
time about his voracious consumption of
soda specifically plain is deeply
attached to tab
um
man so the washington post in a hit
piece about ron clayne and how he is
botching everything they do make sure to
note that he's a super nice guy who
loves tab which is which is fascinating
meanwhile the white house has no idea
what joe biden does on a daily basis jen
saki yesterday was asked what joe biden
was doing you know while russia was
threatening ukraine's border and while
inflation was running out of control so
so here was jensaki's answer as to what
joe biden was doing yesterday
so the president has nothing on his
schedule today aside from the pdb can
you shed any light on on how he's
spending his day
well let's see um this morning i think
he had some policy meetings uh also a
pdb meeting um he um later this
afternoon i think is doing some
remarks review there are some days that
we spend some time doing internal
meetings and discussions uh with policy
experts with policy leaders um and
that's that's what's happening today
so much is happening today actually what
was biden doing yesterday who's getting
ice cream
so uh yeah there's joe eating ice cream
because this is what makes him popular
is being incompetent and and half senile
and eating lots of ice cream so that's
exciting also this administration laser
focused on the problems of the people
here was kamala harris the wildly
unpopular vice president yesterday
talking about where this administration
has put its focus
we are focused on the most vulnerable
and based on my experience the most
vulnerable
are women and girls
racial and ethnic minorities
lgbtqi plus people
indigenous people
people with disabilities
migrants
and children in the foster care system
when we identify who is most vulnerable
we can tailor our tactics
and improve our strategy
so all of their tactics are tailored
toward the most vulnerable which
includes the majority of american
citizens i like how she just throws
women in there women are the most
vulnerable women out earn men straight
out of college right now okay women have
far more college degrees than men do
they have more graduate degrees than men
do women are among the victimized when
you add women just
women
as a category to that litany of the
victimized in american society she's now
talking about about 70 of the american
population right all racial minorities
and all women that would be like 70 of
the american population basically she
should have just had everyone who is not
a straight white male everyone is not a
straight white male is a victim in our
society and she's saying this from her
purchase vice president of the united
states saying we are going to direct
policy to the benefit of these specific
groups which actually suggests that the
people who are the victims of the kamala
harris joe biden administration are the
straight white males and she is
explicitly saying the only people she is
not governing on behalf of are the
straight white males which is pretty
astonishing so it's a good thing things
are things are going great for the for
the biden administration just across the
board just astonishingly well meanwhile
joe biden did take a break from eating
ice cream yesterday to say that russia
invading ukraine could change the world
it would be the biggest invasion since
world war ii um he's not wrong about
that the only question is why he set up
an incentive structure so that russia
would invade ukraine again
there will be enormous consequences
if he were to go in and invade as he
could the entire country
or a lot less than that as well
for russia not only in terms of
economic consequences and political
consequences but will be enormous
consequences worldwide
this would be the largest if he were to
move in with all those forced to be the
largest invasion since world war ii it
would change the world
okay now biden has has started to make
some moves that are a little more
aggressive yesterday he was not going to
rule out sanctioning vladimir putin
personally so freezing foreign bank
accounts although vlad is not really
going to care i mean he's hidden his
money in a variety of places including
places that the west does not have
control over here was joe biden saying
yesterday that he's not going to rule
out sanctioning vladimir putin
personally
watching one of you on television
pointing out the fact that
i think you've got it right whoever it
was i'm embarrassed i don't remember who
saying that this is all putin i don't
think even his people know for certain
what he's going to do would you ever see
yourself personally sanctioning him if
he did invade ukraine yes
you would i would see that
okay in positive moves and you got to
give credit where it's due the
administration did announce on tuesday
it would work with gas and crude oil
suppliers from the middle east north
africa and asia to bolster supplies to
europe in the coming weeks should russia
try to cut off fuel shipments in the
escalating conflict over ukraine
according to the new york times european
allies have been cautious in public
about how far they would go in placing
severe sanctions on moscow if it invades
ukraine germany has been especially wary
because the germans can always be
counted upon to side with the world's
worst humans in conflict of this sword
okay with that said you know what had
been a lot easier is if we had not
greenlit the nordstrom 2 pipeline and
allowed europe to become significantly
more dependent on the on the russian
natural gas and oil industry that
definitely would have been a lot better
to start okay in just one second we will
talk about the immigration problems that
continue to plague this administration
as well plus we need to get to i think
some some insane cultural battles of the
day first let's talk about how much
money you are spending on gas so you
think that the russians are in control
of the european gas supply well over
here in the united states thanks to
canceling things like the keystone xl
pipeline and making us more dependent on
foreign oil as well as inflation your
gas is just too expensive well what if i
told you
there was a way for you to be saving 25
cents per gallon on every gallon of gas
that you get well that's exactly what's
happening with the free get upside app
you can get that free get upside app in
the app store or google play right now
use promo code shapiro get a bonus 25
cents per gallon on your first fill up
that's up to 50 cents cash back don't
pay full price of the pump anymore get
cash back using it get upside just
download the app for free use promo code
shapiro get up to 50 cents per gallon
cash back on your very first tank of gas
some people who drive a lot are making
as much as two to three hundred bucks a
year in cash back there is no catch the
cash back gets added directly to your
account you can cash out anytime your
bank account paypal or an e-gift card
for amazon and other brands just
download that free get upside app use
promo code shapiro get up to 50 cents
per gallon cash back on your very first
tank of gas that is promo code shapiro
when you get that free get upside app
and get up to 50 cents per gallon on
your first tank of gas and 25 cents per
gallon after that alrighty so
meanwhile the when it comes to the the
ukraine situation the good news is that
this administration is so in control of
themselves that uh they're mocking
donald trump so peter ducey
or as joe biden calls him that son of a
peter ducey asked the biden
administration asked shinsaki about
whether a hashtag has ever stopped an
authoritarian since it seems like this
administration is very into hashtag
diplomacy so here is jensaki turning
that around and trying to ridicule
donald trump over it
the secretary of state a few days ago
tweeted
i hashtag
stand with ukraine
has that ever worked
at stopping an authoritarian regime from
doing anything a hashtag
i will have to say that unlike the last
administration we don't think twitter is
the only means of engaging or
negotiating or discussing important
topics
okay well that's not true i mean i'm
sorry but that's not true it was barack
obama's administration where jen saki
was holding up the hashtag free our
girls or whatever it was with regard to
boko haram so hashtag diplomacy started
under barack obama but of course it is
always about trump and trump and nothing
else because they've got nothing else i
mean meanwhile they're just releasing
single migrants into the united states
according to the new york post dozens of
single mostly male adult migrants were
shuttled from a makeshift processing
center in texas to a local airport for
flights to various united states cities
marking the first time such transfer has
been captured on video amid the ongoing
border crisis according to a report on
tuesday the scene began unfolding sunday
outside a parking garage in brownsville
where a makeshift processing center was
set up in a vacant office according to
fox news a video recording shows a line
of men and women being escorted into the
office after which some of them left and
got into taxi cabs that arrived to pick
them up
fox news said it followed the caps
valley international airport in
harlingen about 30 minutes away where
some of the migrants reportedly said
they'd been smuggling across the border
with mexico after paying a criminal
cartel two thousand bucks apiece the
migrants said they were hand headed to
atlanta houston and miami according to
fox news
that revelation came one day after
updated figures from u.s customs and
border protection showed that more than
000 migrants were apprehended at the
southern border last month
almost 200 000 migrants were apprehended
at the southern border last month the
highest number for any december on
record
the figure is higher than the total
number of migrants 175 000 stopped
during the past three decembers combined
combined
so you by the way you notice which
cities these migrants are going to
atlanta houston and miami in other words
southern cities with jobs that is where
they are going
the shuttling of migrants into the
interior of the united states echoes a
new york post report last year in which
plane loads of underage migrants were
flown into the westchester county
airport north of new york city
the post saw some of those children
transported in buses to a non-profit
residential center on long island and to
a service area on the new jersey
turnpike where they were met by
unidentified adults and driven away in
cars
fox news said what it witnessed was
unusual because single adult migrants
typically are expelled from the united
states under a federal law known as
title 42 which allows the government to
deny people entry to prevent the spread
of covet 19.
trump invoked title 42 after the cover
19 pandemic struck and joe biden
continued the practice so jen saki was
asked about this why are we now
releasing single migrants into the
united states why are hundreds of
thousands of migrants arriving on
america's southern border under joe
biden by the way all these people are
arriving because they know they'll never
be deported because joe biden is never
going to deport illegal immigrants
period end of story he wants the border
open he wants the census data to reflect
a huge number of migrants from countries
south of the border because his
presumption is whether it's accurate or
not his presumption is that these people
will vote democrat that is joe biden's
presumption that is the reason he's not
closing the border he has every ability
to turn people away has every ability to
send people back south of the border and
he has worked diligently to undermine
many of the same agreements that donald
trump put in place and then of course
joe biden when he gets caught with his
hand in the cookie jar he's had to put
those agreements back in place like the
remain in mexico policy where people are
supposed to wait in mexico before being
granted the capacity to apply for asylum
in the united states gensake was asked
about what was caught on video yesterday
and she said she knows nothing nothing
why is it that large numbers of single
adult men are being released into the
united states just hours after being
apprehended at the southern border
well i'm not sure the specifics of what
you're referring to peter uh what i can
tell you in terms of what our policy is
and how we're approaching the border is
that we continue to be under title 42 uh
migrants who cannot be expelled under
tidy title 42 are placed into
immigration proceedings and one of those
avenues could be placement in an
alternative to detention program in the
interior of the united states
okay so in other words i don't know
what's going on but also yes we are just
shipping people into the interior of the
united states it's an amazing thing when
this administration is actively
fomenting illegal immigration while
claiming that they are not doing so
which is why you're seeing record
numbers of people attempting to cross
that southern border while joe biden is
president that is what they are they
know this they're saying this they said
this clearly on video multiple times
we've had interviews with people asked
why they are coming now the answer is
because joe biden is president it is
almost impossible how bad this guy is at
this job meanwhile the biden
administration announced on tuesday that
it is withdrawing its current emergency
order mandating large employers
vaccinate or regularly test their
workers for cover 19 instead they are
pushing for a permanent rule so it
doesn't matter that coven 19 is now
endemic it does not matter that omicron
has hit just about everybody that it is
wildly transmissible that you're going
to get it inside work or outside work
but you are going to get it and then
you'll be okay
the occupational health and safety
administration will formally withdraw
its order on wednesday according to a
draft of a memo to be published in the
federal register the agency is not
dropping the rule entirely however
planning to keep the order as a proposed
rule
according to the memo
quote although osha is withdrawing the
vaccination and testing ets as an
enforceable emergency temporary standard
osha is not withdrawing the ets to the
extent that it serves as a proposed rule
under section six
six c three of the act this action does
not affect the ets status as a proposal
under section 6b of the act in other
words they're saying we're withdrawing
this for practical application but we
are using it as a model to try and
develop further osha rules pushing
vaccines
a spokesperson for the labor department
said osha is evaluating the record and
the evolving course of the pandemic osha
has made no determinations at this time
about when or if it will finalize the
vaccination and testing rule the agency
intends to work expeditiously to issue a
final standard that will protect
healthcare workers from covet 19 hazards
okay so it sounds like they are
continuing to withdraw
the the
private business mandate but they're
going to continue to cram down the
health care mandates despite the fact
that you now have states like california
who rather than sending unvaccinated
people who have already had coven 19 and
now have natural immunity back into
hospitals people who are not positive
for cover 19 right towel they would
rather send in vaccinated people with
covet 19 to hospitals which of course
makes no sense whatsoever
meanwhile the biden administration
has decided that it's a great move to
bar states like florida from
distributing
monoclonal antibodies like regeneron
and the the gensake defended the fda's
decision to withhold treatments from
florida specifically and then she
treated monoclonal antibodies as though
they were some sort of mythical cure now
monoclonal antibodies are not working
the way they should against omicron
however they were quite effective with
regard to delta and this administration
spent months downplaying their
effectiveness and then turned around and
basically seized centralized production
and distribution
of the monoclonal antibodies and took
them away from florida
it's so obvious that this administration
is at war with governor desantis in the
state of florida my home state it's it's
it's insane it's really crazy
we have provided 71 000 doses of
antivirals to florida including 34 000
additional treatments that do work
against omicron just this last week i'm
sorry about of a range of those
treatments i should say to be clear what
the fda is making clear is that these
treatments the ones that they are
fighting over that the governor is
fighting over do not work against
omicron and they have side effects that
is what the scientists are saying we
have sent them 20 71 000 doses of
treatments that are effective against
omicron and are effective also against
delta
uh and they are still advocating uh for
treatments that don't work
again why you are preventing people from
getting monoclonal lands i mean they
might have delta right this was
effective against delta it's far less
effective against omicron by the
available data at this point
and again it was the biden
administration that attempted to prevent
the distribution of monoclonal
antibodies in the middle of the delta
spike a little bit earlier this year
meanwhile
ron de santa said that 2000 floridians
had their treatments cancelled because
of joe biden
right like this is this is really
ugly stuff he says it's something we
actually have seen applied with omicron
patients we've seen symptoms resolved
it's not clear this is not something
that's not going to be of benefit
it may not be as good as it was against
delta but we'd like to have that here
for patients to be able to do it
why is the fda openly banning it and
treating it like it's it's some sort of
unproven treatment with regard to other
forms of omicron
this has much more to do with the
politics of distribution than it has to
do with the the
actual
attempts by this administration to
prevent people from taking essentially
placebos
okay meanwhile here's an insane story
for you with regard to with regard to
covid according to the uk daily mail an
unvaccinated gravely ill 31 year old
father of two has now been taken off the
donor list for a heart transplant
because he doesn't want to take the cove
vaccine tj ferguson who has a hereditary
heart condition that causes his lungs
and hearts who filled with blood and
fluid was denied the life-saving organ
transplant by boston brigham and women's
hospital a teaching hospital over at
harvard medical school the hospital said
it removed ferguson from the donor list
because all transplant recipients need
to get the vaccine in order to create
both the best chance for successful
operation and also the patient's
survival after transplantation
the hospital which has a list of
protocols for transplant candidates that
include a ban on lifestyle choices like
smoking and alcohol said that requiring
the covered vaccine is common in many
medical centers throughout the country
mortality rate for transplant recipients
who get coveted is more than 20
according to uc health
ferguson's family is considering
transferring him to another hospital his
wife said that he may be too weak to
move
dr arthur kaplan head of the medical
ethics at nyu grossman school of
medicine told cbs boston vaccination is
a requirement for transplants because
after receiving a new organ patients
immune systems are essentially switched
off they say the flu could kill you a
cold could kill you covet could kill you
the organs are scarce we're not going to
distribute them to someone who has a
poor chance of living when others who
are vaccinated have a better chance
post-surgery of surviving
and this of course is not the first
person who has uh who has been denied a
transplant because of the because of
failure to get vaccinated now
i'm a believer in vaccination i think
that particularly somebody like this who
is severely immunocompromised should
absolutely be getting the vaccine
however if we are going to start playing
this game where we deny life-saving
treatments to people because of personal
decisions with regard to vaccines i'm
just wondering if we can do the same
with obesity right they're doing the
same with smoking and alcoholism so at
least there's a certain level of
consistency there i'm just wondering if
you broadly apply this sort of stuff
across the medical system
are we actually going to hold people
accountable for their healthcare
decisions now i'm okay with it but i'm
just want to know if you guys are on the
libertarian side are you now
libertarians with regards to this sort
of stuff if so then let's be libertarian
all the way across the board okay in
just one second we'll get to some insane
cultural battles that have now broken
out
with regards to the left trying to shut
people down first let's talk about a new
podcast that you should give a listen to
i'm talking of course about the jordan
harbinger podcast this is an
entertaining informative podcast that is
packed with actionable content it's
about time you check out the jordan
harbinger show it's a top shelf podcast
named best of apple in 2018. we are fans
here at the daily wire jordan dives into
the minds of fascinating people from
athletes to authors to scientists to
mobsters to spies you're always going to
get something interesting whether you're
talking about an episode with kobe
bryant or one with dan carlin or maybe
one of scott adams or oliver north
harbinger has an undeniable talent for
getting his guests to share never been
heard before stories and
thought-provoking insights without fail
he pulls out tactical bits of wisdom in
each episode all with a noble cause to
make you more informed more critical
with regard to your thinking and better
able to operate in today's world it's a
great casual listen you might expand
your world view go check them out right
now it's incredibly interesting there's
never a dull show search for the jordan
harbinger show that's h-a-r-b is in boy
i-n as in nancy ger on apple podcast
spotify or wherever you listen to
podcasts you can't go wrong with adding
the jordan harbinger show it's your
podcast rotation alrighty in just one
second we'll get to some insane cultural
stories of the day first the next
episode of adam corolla's comedy series
truth yeller it airs tomorrow adam is
joined by silicon valley actor and
comedian tj miller wears a very short
clip-on tie and takes no prisoners check
it out
we got a guy up here that has a shirt on
that says do not comply
and so i don't have
yeah that's right
and that's nice because i don't have to
ask if you've been vaccinated or if you
care about the elderly or anything like
that
i already know from your shirt i'm like
he'd kill my grandmother and not think a
second time about it
head on over to dailywire.com subscribe
use code miller for 25 off your
membership look out for the new episode
with tj miller it drops tomorrow
also as you know we have launched our
own publishing wing dw books if it is
true it's probably not getting published
by anybody else because we are proud to
be publishing two books actively
fighting the left's monopoly on
storytelling the first is 12 seconds in
the dark by sergeant mattingly this is
the true story of what really happened
the night of the tragic brianna taylor
shooting this became a flash point in
the anti-police wars waged by the left
and now you have the inside story from
sergeant mattingly a 20-year police
veteran it takes readers inside his
department's response and debunks the
lies that have been recklessly shared
with the public this was a book that was
decommissioned by simon schuster simon
schuster was about to publish it and
then they decided we're not going to do
it because we're afraid of the blowback
well we don't care about the blow back
here at dw books in fact we welcome it
dw books is also publishing fiery but
mostly peaceful by julio rosas he's been
a guest on this program he pulls back
the curtain he sets the record straight
on the black lives matter riots that
broke out across the country in 2020 you
were told by the media of course that
these were fiery but mostly peaceful
that they were just wonderfully
enriching to everyone who participated
rose house was reporting from on the
ground he will give you the truth i'm
grateful to have these brave truth
tellers on board can't wait for you to
hear their stories both books are now
available for pre-order on amazon or
anywhere you buy books online you are
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
all righty meanwhile the left continues
its attempts to purge literally everyone
from everything who does not agree with
their points of view so there is a show
it is called real housewives of salt
lake city right it's a spin-off on the
real housewives at sierra's and it is
filled with women who are famous for
doing responsible
and caring and wonderful things for one
another oh wait no it's famous mostly
for women being irresponsible and kind
of to one another that's sort of
the the basis of the show well now
there's one woman who has not made the
cut her name is jenny wen from the real
housewives of salt lake city and she has
been thrown off the show
why because her social media posts were
deemed racially offensive
her old facebook post disparage
protesters and the black lives matter
movement
fans of the reality tv show demanded
that she be fired which fans how many
fans seven it's usually seven fans she
made social media comments amid the 2020
protest that occurred following the
killing of george floyd when apologized
last week never do that never ever ever
apologize it is a waste of time see in a
normal world you apologize for stuff you
do wrong but in this world even if you
apologize for stuff you do wrong that's
just an excuse for them to chop off your
head bravo said in a statement we
recognized we failed to take appropriate
action once her offensive social media
posts were brought to our attention
moving forward we'll work to improve our
processes to ensure we make better
informed and thoughtful casting
decisions
she
said that she regretted writing her
remarks that i want to acknowledge and
apologize for my deleted posts from 2020
that resurfaced at the time i thought i
was speaking out against violence i've
since learned how offensive and hurtful
my words were i regret these posts i'm
sincerely sorry for the pain they caused
now one of the things that is super
annoying about
the articles like this they never tell
you exactly what she said okay so you
actually have to dig to find what she
said that was so horrifying and
terrifying and absolutely evil and and
just just the worst thing in in the
world
okay so what did she do
okay well she um she called some people
who were burning things and hurting
people blm thugs and violent gangs
oh no that's terrible that's that's
super racist why
why if you set things on fire and hurt
people i'm pretty sure you should be
called the thug i don't care what your
race is if you if you set fire to things
and hurt people and you're associated
with black lives matter this makes you a
black lives matter thug just as if you
are associated with antifa this makes
you an antifa thug and if you're a
person who's beating up a cop on january
6 through january 6 thug like this is an
all-purpose word as it turns out but
you're apparently not supposed to say it
when it's associated with black lives
matter
what exactly did she do that was so
terrible
she said quote hundreds of blacks shot
many killed including children by other
blacks every week over a thousand
officers violently injured some
permanently by rioters anarchists
rioting in major cities every night
which has caused billions of dollars of
destruction to private and public
property and you still think police
officers are the problem you are an
idiot
this gets you fired now
really like you say that police are the
solution to crime and that the real
problem for the black community when it
comes to violence against black citizens
is other black people just like the real
problem for the white community when it
comes to violence is generally other
white people
and the cops aren't the problem this
gets you fired now
like i i don't understand how this this
is this is super duper terrible
okay and then apparently she showed
another meme and it showed two cartoon
characters one an elderly white woman
and the other a middle-aged white man
talking with a man staring at six
figures bumper stickers on the back of
her car that normally represent family
members he said no that's not my family
that's how many rioters i've hit the
cartoon white woman said
okay i mean politically incorrect sure
is that racist it doesn't say the race
of the people they could have been
antifa protesters also
and then there was another one that she
posted that was a picture of ken jong's
character from community shouting and it
said if you follow the officer's orders
you won't get shot
okay
i mean
all right this now gets you can because
a few idiots right into bravo now listen
i don't care what happens on the real
housewives of salt lake city i've never
seen an episode i will never watch an
episode because i would rather gouge out
my own eyeballs with a spoon than watch
an episode of a show like that with that
said should the lady lose her job
because she said that she likes the cops
and she doesn't like rioters i'm
confused are you supposed to hate the
cops and love apparently
apparently that is what is necessary
right now so that's good
meanwhile apparently we are going to get
the politically correct version of snow
white and the seven dwarves if peter
dinklage has his way so peter dinklage
is of course
the uh the
actor from game of thrones and and he
was in uh one of the avengers movies
avengers end game i think
and um
and he's very angry at snow white and
the seven dwarves he calls it a an
effing backwards story
he said there's a lot of hypocrisy going
on literally no offense to anyone but i
was a little taken aback when they were
very proud to cast a latina actress as
snow white but you're still still
telling the story of snow white and the
seven dwarves
okay so i mean i'm glad that he's
allowed to say it it is sort of bizarre
that the the story is is about a woman
literally named snow white but
it's a latina actress i mean that it's
strange i mean you can say it's a little
counterintuitive casting but what he's
really mad about is that the studio
depicts dwarves in snow white and the
seven dwarves he says you're progressive
in one way but then you're still making
that effing backwards story about seven
dwarves living in a cave together what
the f are you doing man have i done
nothing to advance the cause for my
soapbox i guess i'm not loud enough i
don't know which studio that is but they
were so proud he knows exactly which
studio it was he just wants to work for
disney in the future because marvel is
owned by disney
by the way peter dinklage complaining
that that stereotypes about dwarves are
used in entertainment the man would not
have a career if stereotypes about
dwarves were not used in entertainment
i'm sorry to say that but it happens to
be the case i mean game of thrones he
literally plays a dwarf right and then
that dwarf violates a lot of the
stereotypes but that is part of the
story right that is part of what game of
thrones is playing upon as matt walsh
pointed out he is correct
the entire shtick that he had an elf was
a joke about him being a dwarf and then
will ferrell thinking that he was an elf
because of it and him being offended by
it
i mean it happens to be the case that
peter dinklage i mean this this is his
role in literally every movie gets cast
because of his stature i mean this this
is not
pretend like
isn't he a new production of cyrano de
bergerac i think it's because of this
again again this is not a negative about
dwarves about people who suffer from
dwarfism that's that's not uh people who
have dwarfism i hesitate to say suffer
from because there are a lot of people
who have dwarfism who are not suffering
from dwarfism in any case people who
have dwarfism
are cast in movies largely because of
their dwarfism and this happens to be
the case with peter's english also are
we supposed to pretend that the dwarves
of myth are the same as just people
suffering from dwarfism now like this is
the same thing
there are many many tales throughout the
the myths of of the norse gods that that
are related to
dwarves right those dwarves also have
other characteristics like they mine a
lot and and churn the earth and all of
this sort of stuff
is all that offensive to dwarves now
like what
okay but we're supposed to
what just kowtow to to peter dinklage
because he has some notes about the
grimm brothers
pretty incredible meanwhile you have
neil young telling spotify that they
should either pull his music or pull joe
rogan well i guess it's goodbye to neil
young then
because joe rogan has 11 million
listeners per episode so um
catch you later neil
it is incredible how much celebrities
think they get to reshape the culture
around us based on the fact that we
recognize some of their music and some
of their faces
alrighty we've reached the end of
today's program however we'll be back
here later today with an additional hour
of content coming up soon as the matte
wall show it airs at 1 30 pm eastern be
sure to check it out over at
dailywire.com i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover and our production manager
is pavo wiedowski associate producer
bradford carrington editing is by adam's
high events audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is by fabiola
cristina production assistant jessica
crand the ben shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
on the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show